safety meeting we're live hello good
morning good afternoon good evening
wherever the hell you are in the world
and uh I wonder where Santa is right now
they've only got the app that tells you
where Santa is right now he's there
he's sorry but I'm sany
Dita merry Christmas everybody how are
you
all doing well doing well cheers the
excited is because I'm Jager fueled at
the moment hang on I've got you I've got
you coming out with my speakers there
you
go idit anyway Merry Christmas and
welcome to Sidra your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel and I'm assuming we'll get
no viewers because everybody's actually
spending time with their families rather
than listening to us Muppets I mean is
dead laur's here Sarah's here mr's here
Merry Christmas guys we currently have
12 people who don't care about their
families
awesome Merry
Christmas um it's like I said isn't it
this is a distraction from your children
who you really need to avoid for the
next two or three days as much as
possible Dad how do I put Dad where are
the batches dad where's the screwdriver
screwdriver can't put this Lego
together sorry my kids are teenagers now
I miss that my teen my teen kids no
don't give a crap about Christmas just
one I don't wants to go out with his
mates like okay anyway like don't get us
socks he wants to go out with his mates
on Christmas what's he gonna do
Christmas day yeah he want with his
mates are you kidding me that's
literally when whenever you are off I
mean this was just a few years ago for
me whenever you're off of school for
that like two or three week period you
spend every waking minute with your
people you can you know yeah but you
spend so I can't relate to that I had no
friends
I this is my
friend you three are my
friends I used to every every Christmas
Day I would log on to RuneScape that's
how sad I was I would log on to
RuneScape and there'd be no one there
because everyone was like you know with
their
[Music]
families and I'd just be there in the
grand exchange just like Hello to like
the three people who also didn't have
friends this feels like a like a sad
Christmas tale this is like the start
of
T Christmas Past anybody have Christmas
present and Christmas future well you're
gonna be Christmas um because you gotta
be young don't you for Christmas Past
I'm Christmas present because I'm jolly
and so happy and um Christmas
future there the three ghosts are going
to visit Matt and then by by the morning
you'll be I could kill the bug no I
didn't damn Let It Go um and then by the
morning Matt will be um
happy by way mad has two te's I'm just
want to
say Matt has two T's I I've waited a
whole year like every conversation we've
ever had with any group chat we've ever
had he's called me Matt with one t and
it's always annoyed me because it's it's
not match is it it's not mat Matt one t
Matt Matt with one t is what you put on
the do on the door on the on the door
the door
Matt mat with two keys because it's
Matthew well I'll call you Matthew then
don't call me Matthew call me mat want
or you call him call him f t
ew someone at work has started calling
me Hugh yes it was M been my boss's boss
has started calling me Hugh and I don't
know feel about that
yeah yeah Matt great Matt makes great
videos but he spelled your name wrong
look mate he's put two T's more see
virtual Sky Studios he's a real one what
are you Jay oh I do he no he's virtual
it says it in the title who's he
standing next to what is that he's got
like a cool little Fedora mustache but
he's standing next to somebody cool
there I just can't tell is that his
Dennis he's got a cooler picture than me
to be fair um just let you know um yeah
the first season of peripheral Harris
was actually very good um it got
canceled basically because it was
horrendously expensive and not many
people watched it um but it was really
good it was mind Bender serious
something like didn't it got cancelled I
didn't go damn it that was a good show I
really like it it's the one with Chloe
Grace morrettes right right right right
yeah it was
just I know they were having problems
with getting her back as well though
because like I think they're going to
have a problem with this in a few um
things coming up in the next 12 months I
think we're going to problem s with
different projects getting canceled or
moved because everyone's likeed all
their calendar sort of thing so
everyone's like yeah but I'm already I'm
contracted to do this in June I can't do
that for the next you know so we are
gonna have problems with different
things yeah all these timelines got
screwed up with the St big time yeah
plans for like basically the next 12
months are all screwed up but anyway
apparently Amazon are all ready to go in
the new year they're all good they
they've sorted it out and I actually I
spoke to somebody last week you know
they're saying about getting the um all
the studio spaces and going and
everything apparently that came from
like right at the top they just went now
this when the strike's not going to end
now until the new year at it's probably
January or February so don't book
anything um so they were actually told
not to and then when the strikes ended
they told okay so when can get started
apparently the guy who's in charge of
like um generally do it went well the
new year because that's what you said
they went what CA a massive argument
I did what you told me to do why are you
shouting at me um but but yeah but
apparently they're all sorted for the
new
year well that's
good anyway how are we all announcement
when
please uh
[Music]
June so what D Dune what' you say June
he said when's the star announcement
[Music]
June hey that's okay San Diego Comicon
yeah and it will be a
movie but I'm going to talk about that
in a video coming up next
week my argument did win at the end of
the day yeah yeah you won hey mate if we
get a movie or anything we all win true
that's that that was the ultimate point
so let's all show off our Christmas
jumpers and look I've got a
reindeer Harris has got a murdered
reindeer right behind him is is that
knuckles in this as the state of Texas
is it like brass
knuckles little on us we don't get snow
too
often oh oh it looked like brass knuckle
like some sort of crazy Texas style
brass knuckles you put your there could
be brass knuckles under the snow and we
let the snow drip on top of them just
Christmas B fight
yeah like strapping on
Christmas one thing we were going to
talk about before the mentalness really
kicks in was what we've enjoyed or not
so enjoyed um in 2023 and then next week
we're thinking we're going to do a look
forward to 2024 aren't we what we're
looking forward to but before we do that
has anybody seen New Moon A New Moon is
that right I just Rebel Rebel Moon as
soon as I said it went no I'm pretty
sure that's a vampire movie Rebel moon
no Rebel Moon I saw it last night I saw
it two nights ago yeah what did you
think you know I I gotta say I kind of
liked it it had that whole you know
Snider 300 kind of vibe to it you know
the way it was shot and
um and then I fell asleep for the Big M
scene but I did like it you know I I did
like you know chasing everybody down
building up the crew that was It was
kind of cool
Harris to say well I expected to
absolutely hate the movie and I enjoyed
it a lot more than I thought I would but
wait you expected to hate it you were
the one hyping it up the mo the most out
of all of us you would shut up about it
I'm intrigued the most probably we all
thought you had like no no we were
talking Rebel moon is the next you you
you were lit you can go back watch any
of that because it is Zack Snider I
never would have said anything like I
just don't trust Snyder films enough I I
I couldn't have said anything like that
because I just don't trust the guy film
making wise enough he's a good filmmaker
sometimes
but he's just so iffy and this one is
full of the iffiness uh but even with
all that there it still got me just
because I I love me some fantasy sci-fi
kind of stuff so it's it was the
definition of a turn the brain off and
just enjoy kind of thing but the second
I am so judgy sorry virtual Sky that's
why I moved to Hollywood that's I Gotta
Be You Know Jud
you uh uh and there ain't no art in in
any Rebel moon it's literally the the
thing about it that the more I think
about it the more it aggravates me but
I'm trying not to think about it very
much because quite liked it but now
you've started I hate it well okay so
the thing that bugs me about it is the
fact that there's a SN cut coming out
about it where you could just tell that
this movie is not the movie they wanted
to make this is this is not the this is
not Rebel moon this is not Rebel Moon
the next version of the movie that comes
out is Rebel Moon that's what bugs me
the most about it where you're going to
totally get a whole different thing uh
just enjoy it
that so so we get in a Snider cut as
well yeah that's the thing you're cut a
what's the point what's the point why
not just make why not just have the
Snider cut that's the thing never
understood that Justice because they're
funneling it down your throat instead of
actually giving you something that's
gonna like be good it needs to be a good
Standalone movie and it just all I'm
saying is Jesus in the book I read when
I was a kid was way more forgiving than
Tex and Jesus [__] I am
Jesus he is an angry little fell look in
Texas Jesus
um on Christmas T Texas Jesus
T
somebody Tex to get that yeah oh lovely
lovely lovely what's you adding to that
what's that cranberry juice yeah it well
what this is this is a cranberry excuse
me this is a Christmas berry Jin bomb so
it's got Bombay Bramble in it which is a
Blackberry raspberry infused gin then
the bottom of the cup has frozen uh
berries in it raspberry strawberry blue
blueberry then I top it off with a
Sparkling Ice raspberry black raspberry
spritzer if you carry on drinking like
that you 'll be in bed by
10:00
okay what time is it there actually
it's oh it is 10 okay there so strong
time travel will be
[Laughter]
involved oh Bob's got a new girl new
chat girlfriend I have to
keep all right heav
when Christmas present because then you
need you need to be suggestive but then
pretend I was just being cheeky because
I was a bit drunk and see how she reacts
know if she's a keeper or not don't send
any unsolicited pictures no unsolicited
pictures
yes
pleas definitely no butt
[Music]
plugs see what David's
saying I could go off about down my
first beer I'm cracking open a r good
man move on anyway my thought about New
Moon was um I was expecting like a
sci-fi film and it was about vampires
weird um uh that Rebel moon was all
right um I I I just I put a note on this
yesterday when I I put it on the
Community page I couldn't help but
wonder why Taran was flying around on
book Beak from Harry Potter for ages
that was a bit strange um and then he's
always in the background about Taran
wandering around was like what film am I
watching why is Taran in this um I spent
the whole time trying to figure out
where I knew the woman from that stars
in it so I spent the whole film
going I know her from something and then
I realized it was she was in a Star Trek
movie um so that that bugged me so I
missed half the film and then I was just
waiting for the Three Amigos to turn up
because I'm like pretty sure this is the
Three Amigos film just in space so at
some point I was waiting for the Three
Amigos and Amigos if Chevy Chase Martin
Short and Steve Martin popped up I would
have been so much happier than what
happened
much better film much better film I love
that Gomez just give us the only murders
in the building version of The Three
Amigos and I'll be just as happy I'd be
just yeah
man of that chick brilliant and then I
did spend a lot of my time wondering why
the chick who starred in it who's a
brilliant actress wasn't wearing a bra
um and I don't oh the the the main girl
Sophia Bella yeah yeah and I was okay
with it but I just spent she's been I
really like Sophia battel as an actress
and I've always thought she needs to get
more roles and bigger roles but just
before we keep moving with Rebel moon or
moving past it did she carry the movie
was she did she carry the film as a lead
actress
no not really think so I love the
actress a lot I really think she's
talented I just don't think she's a lead
in this degree you know she did a great
job and physically she was on point
yeah fight
fantastic the general guy was he's the
he's the best actor in the bunch with
he's he's got so much
gravitas yeah oh my God that guy's
amazing if he was the main guy I think
this would film would more I just think
it's it's a storyline that's been done a
lot um and they took a long time
introducing each character it felt more
like a TV series by the pacing so it was
like because this is like a two-hour
this is like the opening to a new series
that's what it felt like the PAC because
oh what are you doing I'm doing a bit of
digging why and that went on for
ages um oh got a big rock and I'm I'm
gonna slowly move it out the way okay
quick crack on um it just it but but I
have to say beautifully filmed I mean
God all the way I'm thinking God I wish
a bigger Telly I wish I was watching to
the cinema but man there a couple of
dodgy effects once or twice though um
Taran on the back of book Beak was
really two-dimensional it really made me
like go oh gez that was a bad effect um
but on the whole I thought yeah it was
great thought it really
good yeah I liked it overall but it it
hit all the spots that I thought it
would hit yeah which was expected I
think it's a good thing that when when
you for me it's not a great sign of a
movie when you spend half the time on
IMDb trying to figure out where you knew
the woman from and then you spent half
the the next of it trying to figure out
the main bad guy in it what his name was
in Deadpool and I'm like Frankie it's
not
Frankie he Deadpool spelled it out in
dead bodies at the end what was it I
should have been watching the film it
was Fran I did that with the the trailer
Far Cry there's a b guy in far you know
the know Far Cry far not Far Cry sorry
Fallout oh
yeah there's a ball guy in it and I'm
like I know him from somewhere I don't
know where I know him from and I've SP
ages looking for him Heroes he was in
Heroes
yeah it's always good when
you're the best part about Rebel Moon
though was the fact that they got both
of the Game of Thrones actors that
played Dario and Harris to be pitted
against each other which is kind of
fun oh have a
point don't we know by now bring that up
you bring that up now he said that ages
ago he saw and just remembered it to
something you said to not not not
this oh God there's now 28 people that
hate their families watching us by the
way it was great double in a
couple before we go any youres make sure
you leave a like yes please leave a like
um and share the video to all the other
people that hate children as well if you
could and that would be great I'm gonna
I have a little video to play and I
honestly hope my family doesn't watch
this my family won't watch it they have
no interest in my hobbies at all figure
out streaming so I'm safe my wife said
to my mom yesterday goes um have you
seen Jamie some singing videos mom was
like what because you watch his videos
don't you and she was like oh yeah you
sing and you were singing
channel so she was like what about
singing Because yeah I did a 12 nights
of Christmas and the thing you know she
was like oh right and and my wife made
him put it on but anyway I've also that
looks like the double bubble logo I
don't know what double bubble is I'm
sorry what you want to about I
apparently look like the double bubble
logo because I've got a crown on I don't
what double bubble is I don't know
either is it
American who it's bubble gum America's
original Bubble Gum yeah oh there you go
you guys something there it does look
like I've got a little video it's a
party hat it's a shut up a second this
is very this is very I'm gonna you're
gonna find out in a second but this is
very on point here we go you
said here's a Christmas message from
Santa
J it was the night before Sid Trek and
here we are live sci-fi and silliness
Sundays at
5: Harris is here with all that hair the
rest of us thinking that's bloody
unfair our young American will be a big
star when he stars in the remake of Dude
Where's My
Car stormy is here between building
spaceships always one more question on
his St
lips the resident American daddy of
citrek Gandalf deito is always on
Deck our Tech wizard Matt is here too he
doesn't watch movies unless they are
blue everyone tells him short tall thin
fat even Brad Wright said shut up
Matt Jay's here too hoping he won't need
a we praying this live will will be but
plug
free spilling the beans Amazon doesn't
want you to
know ah I need a wheel already I better
go Merry Christmas Sid
trekers oh what where
stor he's back of course stormy went why
wouldn't stormy wander
off um got another quick little thing to
do and then I I have something to say
for one second one second Merry
Christmas Sid trackers from LC
wa
amazing and you saw what she was
watching back there it was great love
Jenny that's our Jenny Sten really close
friend of the channel and just amazing
she's she's promised she'll be back in
the new year to talk all stuff I just
wanted to quickly thank other people
that appeared on the channel uh like
Mike from the solo one podcast Melvin
from sci-fi quest mark from the shuttle
pod show all the guys from the companion
even Aaron that came on a few times and
we loved him as well and Ma from the FR
um Adventure Network even though he
argues with me a lot um Jim who the hell
is
Jim oh my God oh my God I'm gonna send
that to him oh yeah Jim and Jim that
came on your
mate you mentioned him last week I
forgot about him he was nice I like Jim
um so and Jim came
on yeah just go message him for me and
him I forgot he existed um I will I'll
send him this
videoing right now um not here to be
honest and I did want to very quickly
say that that all three of you guys you
just absolute Legends thank you so much
I don't I don't I try to express my
sorry he's de that know
so um he's dead to me anyway um but no
you guys don't have to come on and do
these videos every week and you do
anyway and it can't be because you like
it so there must be some other reason so
um just just could you pay me £10,000 PS
a month obviously well I've gotta I've
got to spend those big YouTube money
somewhere it's only 10,000 I'm getting
7500 yeah
don't oh I quit yeah we we've muted him
for a reason um he he just gets um butt
plugs uh one a
month just one I thought he had him for
each day well does he know he's he's
muted I think he's figuring it out right
[Laughter]
now no but um yeah just no just just
just you guys just thank you so much I
want sah said it for our appreciation we
are now all going on strike this is the
Sidra strike after the last seven months
of it we're going
like oh
[__] no back back back back back back
back it worked out the exact same way
too anyway but so so yeah Rebel moon
it's all right I don't I didn't mind it
I'm not sure how much did it cost to
make do we know have top of heads I
meant to look it up last night too damn
much huh what was that yeah yeah I think
it I think it did cost you that much to
make but well do
Netflix all the way through though I was
thinking I can see how it was a Star
Trek movie I could see this might have
make more sense as a St a Star Wars
movie sorry it was one for
one 166 million between Parts one and
two how much oh between both 166 million
betweens part one and two that's not
between both a lot better that ain't too
bad especially considering now they're
getting again a
second um
a massive version uh
Jordi I can think I've got a video
coming in a couple of days about this
Jordi but uh it's possible it's very
very unlikely so um end of January early
February if MGM are going to do a series
then they've got their slate
announcement at the end of January early
February so it'll be definitely worth
having a look if Amazon throws a
curveball maybe what I'm being told
though is it's going to be a movie and
they're going to wait to San Diego
ComicCon which will be next June that's
that's as far as I know at the moment
but you never know because we don't know
everything at the end of the day we
don't know everything that's going on in
the halls of Amazon we try waited this
long Stargate like what's another year
like well it's another
two another two years don't say that no
no I I was I was psyching myself up
there Jay and you just ruined it sorry
um they were hoping to release um the
film that was going to be released San
Diego Comic-Con and then that that was
supposed to come out uh spring 2025 so
this will be spring
2026 so we we need to start a campaign
and get me in there as Aris Bach Jr so
we have an inside source like like a
Insight on a daily basis oh Harris
you're not arisp Jr they're gonna go
They're gonna go hard on the the ancient
religions and they're gonna go hard on
Christianity you are Jesus I'll be space
Jesus but I want to be Aris J
how can I be both give me some
Prosthetics haris SP Jr a go W named
Jesus yeah is the stormy are you
back nope you're not back you know sign
language I don't I can look it up
mic inexplicitly is your microphone
dropped can you not no sign language
there yes yes yeah you can hear me
you're back you're back it must think
could been the butt plug filter or
something it just totally muted my mic
I'm so sorry about that H yeah it's
because you don't shove the microphone
oh no forget that let's not go there
let's not let's not go there just gives
him an
idea the better version of our
microphone he's got the blue is that the
yeti the yeti Blue
[Music]
Yeti snowball because it's
cheaper
so but um yeah I am everything in my
life is like can I get that cheaper so
yeah that's literally why I bought mine
because it was it was like 60 quid on
Amazon whereas the yeti was like 120
like fine y it last like five years be
fair so here's an interesting question
the Warner Brothers Paramount merger a
good idea again that's my other video
that's coming out next week talking
about this what do you guys think about
this idea though of Paramount and Warner
Brothers merging and I should say as
well everyone keeps going on about how
Warner how are Warner Brothers going to
buy Paramount they're not it's a it's an
oldfashioned merger it's basically just
a transfer of debt and shares so um it's
they're literally just gonna go we'll do
it together I don't know anything about
this but I think it's a good it's a good
thing that they're merging because we
have too many bloody streaming platforms
they all need to merge into one or at
least like very very few so we have
because because there's too much choice
now you've got Paramount you've got
Amazon you've got Netflix you've got uh
Apple you've all these bloody every
[__] Network in the world decided oh
I want my own streaming platform I'm not
going to pay for all of that I'm GNA pay
for like the big the big like three
which well the big two for me which is
Netflix and Amazon and listen to what
the drunk wise King he knows what he's
talking about um I'm talking I'm talking
just as a regular consumer here like
there's too many bloody streaming
platforms like I say the rumor is
Netflix are going to take over Paramount
plus and Max but that won't affect us
anyway mate because we don't have Max in
the UK it's that's what sky Atlantic is
basically so unless something changes um
but but they will still run it as three
separate channels that you then have to
like pay for a
bundle is doing where they're having
like basically being like a conglomerate
like you can buy all these subscriptions
from us thing I like that idea because I
can have a subscription to Prime and if
I want to then subscribe to MGM I can
through the subscription I already have
without having to download another app
which is annoying or go to another
website which is annoying like because
I'll have to download on my phone and on
my TV which is
annoying
just there's too many and then they then
they shut down some point as well
yeah oh you've got all the mini ones the
mini ones on Amazon annoy me like we've
got lion ska and MGM plus okay um but
there's there's loads of stars and
there's loads of them and it's like oh
come on man I'm not what I'm not paying
six quid for three films and and a
million films I've never heard of I'm
not doing it but the one film I want
will be on there my wife wanted to watch
Love Actually no it wasn't actually what
was
it she wanted to watch something anyway
and it was only on Lion gate this
Channel and there was the only place it
was so I had to put the free view on it
and then Krampus was on there and that's
brilliant chance um but I just put do in
the UK you've you've got I player
Channel 4 channel 5 uh ITV X and then
you've got Brit box as well which
britbox I think I'm pretty sure was
supposed to just be all of British
TV yet they still have their own
streaming platforms just make one
yeah well
most [__] TV license but anyway go on
stormy sorry mate yeah I never did
understand Brit box I get ads for it all
the time on H Facebook and I go over
there and it's like one or two shows
that I actually remember
and but and then it's just like it seems
like it's all it's for me it seems like
it's second run BBC
shows it is the only reason I ever had
it was because of Doctor Who I only ever
it because of Doctor Who and then Doctor
Who basically stuck everything from the
classic series and the movie onto I
player like why do I need brickbox just
get rid of it I play every other show
every other show is on brickbox and it's
on other streaming
platforms yeah it you know I used to go
to watch Pluto TV for all the classic um
Doctor Who shows but then they started
selling them on Apple TV and so I just
[__] bought them I got
I got tired of chasing them all around
you know and they're really Dirt Cheap
like a couple bucks for a whole season
and so I I'll just buy oh shoot buy them
all and uh and stop chasing them you
know yeah I was say I think the merge is
a good idea from a business point of
view anyway because these are two
companies that are seriously struggling
and they can cut their costs massively
with a merger there are lots of things
that they're both doing that they could
the animation studio was I spoke to
somebody and they said this the
animation studio is his example and he
basically said look Warner Brothers have
got this enormous um Animation studio
and Paramount and CBS have got a pretty
big one as well with like Cartoon
Network and stuff they can just move all
that to Warner Brothers and shut all the
rest of it down and it'd be way way they
and really without affecting like
productivity particularly so
um
yeah um but but yeah I mean
it's it makes sense me these are two
companies owe look Paramount is worth on
the stock market about 10 billion but it
owes 15 billion um Warner Brothers is
worth about 30 billion but it owes 50
billion they owe at the end of the day
if you owe more on your house than it's
worth you've got a problem so these
companies have got a problem with seem
to have a plan to pay that debt off over
about a 10e period or get that debt to
um sort of a reasonable level it needs
to be about half of your net worth the
reckon to be like reasonable level so um
they need to get that debt down to
around what paramounts is now basically
they need to owe no more than about 15
billion in the next 10 years but that's
the pl so but just selling off loads of
real estate they're going to be able to
sell off loads of real estate that they
owe um that they own so let's see but
it's a massively complicated deal it
might not happen yet the the at least
for me the thing that it
um I don't know if this is a good thing
or a bad thing but the merger will make
it a lot easier for Disney to buy the
whole thing Disney or
apple or apple I hadn't thought about
Apple but you know Disney I mean with
all that debt load I mean Disney's kind
of you know struggling also but in terms
of the whole world of Disney it' make
him easier to uh snatch it all
I don't think
they' I just because they already bought
Fox I think that would become too much
of a film Monopoly where they wouldn't
allow that and if Apple did
it I think Apple's the only viable
option because they got the cash and
they're not big enough in the film
industry as of yet where it would be a
monopoly in that aspect of things you
know where um that's true Apple's got
what hundred billion dollars in checking
I mean it's insane how much cash on hand
Apple has
just do you remember in um Demolition
Man that they had the um like the
takeaway Wars and Taco Bell W yes we
we're supposedly getting Demolition Man
Two next year or year after so they're
going to be like they've got to do a
joke of that Apple won the streaming
Wars
or some won streaming Wars and then
that's now all of the streaming services
are just apple or um kind of Disney
that's that's no fun it's got to be
somebody really ridiculous one so let's
see but um
yeah 20 years
ago KFC W the stream the streaming
Wars
let's yeah um for Star Trek and babyon 5
though and things like this I don't
think it'll make any difference it'll
make them more likely because they'll
have a I was watching um Trek yard or
something yesterday and they were saying
oh maybe he'll get bigger budget for
Star Trek Star Trek doesn't need a
bigger budget it gets like $10 million
an episode its budget is fine what it
needs a company behind it that can
afford the budget that they've been
given it so um it'll it'll make the
companies more secure which is only a
good thing I think so if they allow if
FDC let them do it which they might not
so um do you think if they do merge
which might be jarring for in the short
term but I do it's a good thing in the
long term do you think that it will
increase like the likelihood
specifically for Star Trek that Bad
Robot is already kind of inhouse for
Warner Brothers do you think they're
going to find their way back into the
fold
somehow we could get more Abrams Star
Treks it could help
that
um I don't think bad robots contract
with Warner Brothers will be extended so
think that runs out this summer I think
yeah it's not long whatever it is it's
either this summer or very early um 2025
I think um something like that so um and
excuse me sorry I've got a bit of a head
call so I'm gonna cough occasionally is
that the Jager um it's it's not the
Jager helped helped lovely it just
warming um but um yeah so I don't think
that's going to be a major problem Bad
Robot at the end of the day how long's
it been since covid
now ended two years everyone's back to
work don't they and bad BR has still
done nothing for um Warner BRS they've
still really nothing and they've got
this exclusivity
deal um that company is just ruined at
the moment so we'll see what
happens but um they they've live
literally I mean they I think they're
co-producing a couple of projects but
even a couple things like speed race
that they were supposed to do for Apple
that's been canc as well yeah
they can't seem to get anything out the
door just like you've got these
brilliant ideas can any even walk no no
they're all rubbish um so let's see
let's see what happens but anyway we
were supposed to pick a movie that we've
loved and a movie we've hated this year
and a TV series we've loved and a TV
series we've hated both of Matt's movies
are both porn films so we can skip
that as I said in the video Dallas was
an amazing film um it was oh the
cinematography the lighting was amazing
they got an Oscar for that didn't they
for the editing I believe yeah isn't it
funny that anybody mentions porn anybody
doesn't really watch porn immediately
goes to Debbie Does
Dallas it's the POR why not Emanuel or
anything like that it's always W do
Dallas
um but guys what oh I also ask you do a
TV series that's really loved or
surprised you this year and the one that
disappointed you or you really hated
so let's get into it who wants to go
first hands
up
anyone Harris wants to go first that's
nose goes that means I'm I'm not
volunteering yeah but um I told you
about this like a week ago so you're
obviously all prepared even though I can
see stormy Googling it right now to try
to remember what came out in
2023 it's been a blur
I I I will say what I said to you in the
group chat I have not watched any films
this year except for die hard I I don't
I don't watch them I did watch die hard
to be fair and I did like that die hard
was good no problem um we
will with TV shows I'm going first by
the way I've decided Go Go TV show what
TV show surprised you what TV show did
you love this year so I liked Last of Us
I really did that was good really really
enjoy enjoyed it um I was surprised that
I liked it because I thought it was it's
it's a it's a TV show based on a game
and typically they're all [__] like I've
seen the Halo the TV show it was wank
like let's hope the new one does a bit
better yeah so I thought it's based on a
game this isn't gonna be good but I
actually really enjoyed it um with TV
that I
hated uh it's no surprise but it was
manifest
I loved it when it first came out the
first couple of seasons were pretty good
really good I really enjoyed it that's
why I carried on I
got but the last few seasons just they
turned religious everything went to oh
this is a message from God and stuff and
I have no problem with religion in TV
shows I love
Stargate um but it was just a little bit
too you
know too much and and the story was a
bit [__] because yeah it's when they
went too religious and the end they went
Harris did it and we were like oh was
Harris well they basically added in um
they added in Noah's Arc and oh we found
a piece of Noah's Arc and like how the
[__] do you know that's a piece of
Noah's Arc you can date it back for sure
you can definitely date it back but you
cannot with any proof say that is Noah's
Ark these are
scientists
I'll tell the movie I'll tell you the
movies because M doesn't want to throw
into that the movie that really
disappointed me this year and it Ant-Man
and Quantum Mania
oh that I'm I'm actually still
disappointed when I actually thought
about this my first thought was Thor
love and thunder and then I checked and
actually came out in 2022 but I'm so
injured by it I'm still going to say
that is the most disappointing film of
2023 as well um but Ant-Man and quantum
was so disappointed it was it was just
the dude with the big head and the I
mean it was it was I really like the
first two anman movies I really liked
them you know the guy with the big head
from quantam Mania was the same guy from
Rebel Moon that y yeah took on the head
that was excellent David be the
Justified serious was
excellent final manifest was good I've
not got that far I've literally given up
halfway through the last season it was
that bad yeah yeah um but um a movie I
was most surprised by this year it was
the only one I watched last week and
it's not sci-fi but it's Wonka I I
cannot tell you how much I love that
movie it's a a proper instant classic
it's just great it's a really good I've
got that on order I'm going to watch
that with it's properly excellent mate
it's a properly good sequel to the
original and I just that how often does
that happen that you get a classic and
they try to do a sequel and you know and
then I again I was so physically injured
by Johnny Depp's
attempt um I mean I like I like Johnny
Depp's version I love I
love um it's terrible and um it's just
no I sorry I forgot it's Christmas it's
Christmas I'm sorry um shut up you're
wrong what louded
opinion no you're not allow an opinion
when it comes to the Johnny Depp version
of Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
because it was that bad no it was good
it was a different style it's got good
aspects to it but it is inherently I
mean people are always like it's closer
to the RO doll novel no it's not it's I
I just saw it as a very Tim Burton film
just like I hate Tim Burton so that's
thing Tim Burton's allowed to be Tim
Burton Tim Burton needs to go through a
shredder he shouldn't he need somebody
behind him to go Tim Burton and I'm
going oh okay I'm sorry I won't go on
Tim Burton on this I'll control myself
when he hasn't got somebody in his whis
ear going go last Tim Burton he Ty white
Ted that [__] and I just no
no right let me let me justify by saying
the G worlder version is my favorite
version but I still I did enjoy the
Johnny de version and I still I would I
would happily watch
both I don't to justify it I like it
like shut up ask
[Music]
film no no no no
no a virtuous guy Matt is right it was
good Jay is blasphemy the Johnny Depp
version of char in the Chocolate Factory
was not good I like this guy it was
creepy he came across like somebody that
likes children in a different freaking
way it's no you're really
weird yeah
really weird if that guy turned up with
chocolate at your kid School gate you'd
have him arrested and put on a list
no Jean Wilder though you'd be like he
can babysit my kids You' just met him
now sound I actually no no no no Gan
Wilder I don't know if I want either one
of kids like I wouldn't let him name my
kids either I would I'd let come with me
and you'll no go
away only Depp would have been come with
me and was see in the back of my for
Transit no no no no no I'm not having
it not on this channel
baby the singing lessons are paying off
that was kind of in
tune Johnny Depp is only good when
you're in your late 20s and drunk I'm
not sure there's enough
drunk in the planet yeah I'm in my late
20s I'm 31 that's that's very late 20s
very late 20th
Cent let's get on the younger
juice my wife pointed out to me that I
turned 46 in a couple of weeks yeah
thanks for that because you're you're
now closer to 50 than you are
40 merry half a century there's now 39
that hate their families so cheers hey
welcome every time you say it the number
drops every time yeah
there somebody there going oh [__] my
kids oh [__] it's Christmas oh God I
gotta Pretender coming
um stormy how about you hang on what's
this comment I don't understand this
what does this say that is a awesome
Winks Was Won what does that
mean it it sounds like some sort of
dating issue I'm not really sure was
four plus 6 equals 10 so you're Forever
Young I'm I'm as only as old as the um
person inside and I genuinely had a I
seriously right had a psychological
assessment once when I was in a job
years ago um to see whether I was
allowed to um uh do stuff that shouldn't
be allowed to do but anyway they were
they were testing my psychological
assessment and I I failed the
psychological assessment because I I had
moral apparently but the actual
psychologist that did the assessment he
said um you're supposed to be in touch
with your in a child it's not supposed
to be at the driving seat and I took
that as a
compliment I was like
that's my boss was like that's not a
compliment man there was a compliment
how that not a
compliment very much I'm very much in
touch with my inner child like
everything I do is I'm very
childish I would
never I think think that was a compl
honestly that's one of those things that
you say you grumpy old bastard that's
how you reply to
that I was just like you need to yeah do
you still believe shut up old
man
you I'm gonna live forever then
skateboard out the
office I'm gonna live
forever I'm live
forever um but anyway stormy about you
what you what you really love this year
then okay so in terms of movies I gotta
say barbin Heimer I mean I love Barbie I
mean I la I've never laughed that hard
throughout an entire movie in a very
long time I thought it was Oppenheimer
you laugh you laughing all the way
through Oppenheimer we like going I know
what's going to happen at the end is it
that no I I see Barbie Heimer see I like
Barbie because I laughed all the way
through and I loved Oppenheimer uh
because it was very well acted very well
written and I even went to the test site
back in a uh October and just to just to
see it you know because it's right up
the road for me in white
sand yeah yeah yeah
it's I thought those two movies were
exceptional and kind of tied you know uh
I want to say like the unhonorable
mention
was
Renfield Renfield is great I love oh my
God yeah I mean you know with um
Nicholas Cage I just I just loved it and
he was really great in I mean it was
like it was like I guess the old timey
you know Nick Cage when he was just kind
of doing his Nick Cage thing his it was
just glorious it just it was just really
the last two Nick Cage films have been
amazing that film he did I I don't think
he came 2023 but last year that um uh oh
what it's called the hero of oh when he
played himself anyway but that was
unbearable weight of massive Talent yeah
oh God that was a good film it was so
really really good and but Renfield
honestly they should just do a sequel to
that film just with Nick hedge yeah even
though he reckons he's only got a couple
of films left in he's gonna
reti he says the one film I just really
didn't like M was Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 really I was really I
mean it was just was a little there was
one really heartwarming piece and that's
when Rockets rescuing all the little
raccoons I really thought that was well
done but it just seemed like it bounced
along you know it didn't have any the
really emotional impacts that one and
two did you know and I don't know it it
just it's like a lot of things Marvel it
just kind of petered out I thought you
know
what he's gone for alcohol
oh I'm getting a bit drunk I start
feeling in my cheeks when I'm getting I
actually didn't I I did a j I needed to
go to the
toilet why didn't you get alcohol while
you were
there I I had my mes deliver me one yeah
I am gonna text my
mes can you bring me
alol my um there's an ingoing joke in my
house cuz when I got married um my
brother was there and he had his like um
5-year-old my my my nephew um and all we
heard everyone was chatting away and all
we heard was um Sam on the back of his
chair excuse me to the waitress can you
bring me more
alall oh my the whole room went quiet
and just burst laughing so I'm gonna
message my wife saying can you bring the
alol oh my m is
watching
I tell it to did you say a movie that
you enjoyed stormmy um Matt misses can
just tell us the um the last time that
Matt disappointed you if you could put
that in the comments that'd be great
last you're gonna get the boy in trouble
hold up what did you ask Harris yeah did
you say that you enjoyed a whole bunch
this year and uh well you know two said
Barb you said barbin Heimer right yeah
the there was TV TV shows that's yeah
okay yeah the I've got two again two
tied for first you know and both are on
apple plus one is foundation [__]
excellent and For All Mankind I've
really enjoyed the last season of all
mankind it really
is yeah and the um there's a u a runner
up I want my in in terms of favorite TV
shows was the fall of House of Usher was
just really really good I thought you
didn't like it
Matt you know I thought oh oh I see so
in but I thought fall of House of Usher
I thought you know Mark Hamill knocked
it out of the park I really I mean I was
just stumbling through and I said well
this is well oh po I'm always a fan of
Po so I'll just go watch this and it's
like is that Mark Hamill that's Mark
Hamill you right one of the first scenes
it's like and so I just I fell in love
with it but and
um but there were
two there there was one really big
disappointment I had and that was
Walking Dead Daryl
Dixon it I mean the it was the he's in
France and he T somehow and the whole
the whole thing for me was just I
couldn't get out of my head how the hell
did he get from North America to Europe
in a rowboat during you know during I've
wondered this I've not finished walking
dead yet but they they're literally in
the middle of America during the
entirety of Walking Dead how was he in
France it it was it was why would you go
to France unless you absolutely had to
it's half the way or something and it
it's just it was unless he's some sort
of dream sequence which he spent the
whole I mean it's interesting how France
you know um you know handled the the all
all of the Walkers I mean that that's an
interesting story but I couldn't escape
how the hell he got I because the way
they filmed it you know he kind of
escaped this thing and there was this Ro
I don't want to give too many spoilers
away he just kind of drifted across the
Atlantic during winter and he shows up
you
know oh
God and think he's fine he character
that just survives
just survives but
apparently the middle of America to
Europe yeah I can't see that happening
because he'd have to go around the
entirety of Europe to get there yeah and
and I'm sure there' been a lot of
Stories on his you know on Walkers
across you know Alaska and you know
Siberia and anyway but the one that I I
kind of didn't expect to be good and I
was rewarded with being right was Mel
Brook's history of the World Part Two
was haven't seen huh I still haven't
seen it I really wanted to though I
just I wanted to like it but it was
terrible I mean it was jokes from the
60s and 70s that wouldn't have worked in
the 60s and 70s and doesn't work it was
just I don't know and I could be totally
wrong in this but I just I didn't grock
it at
all
Sorry by the way you banned him
yeah I go back and watch you Blazing
Saddles and that's
brilliant then there's maybe it's just
because you know Richard prior didn't
write it I don't know I don't know
yeah I love play settles play and
settles is one of my favorite things
ever um I I love this year oh um TS King
with Sylvester was the thing that
surprised me the most this year I wasn't
expecting to love it quite as much as I
did it's it's so good um I was expecting
Yellowstone because everyone kept
telling me how good Yellowstone was so
when I've watched it I thought yeah this
is I can see why people love this this
is great but Tulsa
King it's it's one of the B
best best things I've seen in years I
just think it's great I cannot wait for
the sequel um 1923 was
brilliant I've not seen it I've not seen
it yet I'm going to I'm I'm watching all
of Yellowstone and then I'll watch I'll
go back to 1923 1883 then 1923 because
18 1923 is freaking great but 1883 very
well may be my favorite miniseries I've
ever seen
like both don't don't wor don't worry
Have you seen b Reeves yet I know you're
on the Taylor Sheridan
route literally just said that I'm not I
haven't got quite that far yet I will be
watching it though um a double check
mark for
me
I I am I am gonna get there I am gonna
get there because it does look
good week I'll tell the wife Harris said
so the Harris what what's this year then
what has surprised you the most
oh
uh surprised me the most tvwise was
blueeyed Samurai that was one that I was
like I keep hearing good things it looks
like it's a really good animation kind
of like style and everything but it was
just like I don't know I I I kept not
wanting to click it and then I finally
clicked it and I watched the whole thing
in a day and a half two and a half days
uh it was it was fan freaking tastic I
think my favorite thing I've seen this
year TV wise was probably scavengers
rain though um just the perfect sci-fi
in so many ways I just loved it but
blueeyed Samurai would be surprising I I
don't think TV wise there was anything
that like disappointed me or pissed me
off a whole bunch thankfully um May
maybe uh what MCU shows came this year
oh there we go secret Invasion secret
Invasion I hated it so much I just
tossed it out of my mind that's the one
that I would uh I didn't so bad I didn't
my mind at all um I I finished watching
secret Invasion and then I sat there on
my own rocking backwards and forwards
going just listing all the reasons why
it didn't make sense um and was She-Hulk
in
2023 yeah it was
yeah that made me angry but if shehulk
was bad secret invasion was was almost
tfold worse she shehulk took the piss
out of out of Marvel fans which is which
was I thought was
Brave in a way it just didn't understand
audience at all P subscri it would like
me sitting in now and literally just go
all you 48 people are watching this
watch you hate your families or
something it's just taking the piss out
of them it's just like you wouldn't do
it um 49 people now that hate their
children um was in 2022
by the way sheas okay so there you go
see the first episode I think I think
the primary of it was 2023 over
Christmas did it so um it was painful
anyway the pain continued through but
secret invasion was just bad there was
nothing about it everything about it was
not very good the only good thing was
Olivia Coleman the only good thing was
Olivia Corman who she was Gren Walker
too but it's because she's British isn't
it yeah yeah it's because she's she can
actually Act because she's British yeah
um so they can be good guys bad guys
anything comedy comedy is always better
when it's British so
yeah we're sexier everything really I
don't know about that one
but you say right here how bad I don't
have enough Sun for anybody to be
there's enough
place I'm not saying we're white sexy we
we're like a pale blue sexy what we're
sexy um Akira nightly come on sexy she
hadn't when was the last time she lived
in
England yeah but she's still
British got out burn through all DNA you
take the girl out of Britain but you
can't take the Britain out of the G yeah
yeah she's got a bit of Britain in her
at all times I'm telling you so car made
an excellent point
there Bri
make
Nazis yeah yeah man I argue that um it's
because if you want to have a Nazi with
a bit of a sense of humor as well you
can't cast a German can you because they
don't they don't know how to do that I
was watching them some yesterday and
they said um how did um how come there
are no funny Germans left and this um
old um TV producer's name I've forgotten
and he and this was on a chat show in
Germany and he said ah it's probably
because you killed them all and then
they went oh uh I went to advert and
came back weirdly that producer was gone
didn't come back um but yeah so that's
why there's no funny Germans anyway um
we do the best at everything when we're
acting because we're just better at it
we're better at everything engineering
as well better at that as
well you come to Texas but you know
um Star Trek for a second I know sunny
mean stormmy but like Star Trek but Star
Trek was my most hated and most loved
thing that happened year
because Star Trek Bard season 3 was one
of the best things I've seen this year I
I was it's the only thing I've had that
I got up every day um I got early the
day it was on to watch I absolutely
loved it and it actually made me
properly
go every day and then Strange New World
season 2 came out and I was irritated a
lot
and then they did the music episode and
I was angry for about three months um
which was entertaining it was just crap
no it was just bad it just bad man so um
yeah those are my two things that I
hated the most um I think that three
months was processing like I really love
Star Trek so I am like just being hard
on the episode and then you watched it
again and then like again and then again
and then you were like you know what
this episode's just
awful it took a little while
there's always going to be some Star
Trek that you just go what the hell but
I mean everything is even when you're
watching like TNG which is like the best
Star Trek they probably did I prefer
Star Trek to Star
Wars what I grew up on Star Wars and
I've been watching Star Trek recently I
prefer 10 fold it's way better we have
50 people that hate their families and
children come on 49 this is how
Christmas starts baby this is Christmas
not eggnog and an open fire with your
families if you all open the stream in
another tab on a different browser it
will double the views and share it to
more people and we can have more people
that don't love I don't trust my Wi-Fi
enough to do
that come with me and you'll see in my
white Transit van um I'm
Unapologetic love strange new worlds no
it strange new worlds is a good show
that's why second season was so
irritating because two or three the
episodes were bloody
awful um on the fifth day of star g r I
gave to
me you know what every time I've heard
that song Beautiful I work in a school
and we had an act of worship and then
like this panto that they did right and
at the end of this panto all the kids
got up and they sang five days of
Christmas and I could not get the bloody
Sidetrack version out of my head yeah
when he got to five five gold rings I
like going
five I just I would have loved I would
have absolutely loved you to do that
that would have been in real life Matt
turns
into we could just get a gold I don't
know I don't know why every time I do
this there's a picture of tilk and it's
great do it and it doesn't do that you
know like that wait why schmoo comes up
my other guy on the channel for Cube
comes up that's not me I was going to
say that's not you you do that is that
because if I just close it I just go out
what is Press cam I don't know why I
thought I thought I was on your
account I knew that was GNA happen but
it was F he just closed his browser or
something because he's disconnected at
the
bottom ah wrong side no I said stop cam
oh no I didn't say Stop Cam I said stop
everything
oh he's T too I T storm is just your
normal thing yeah I'm just yeah I'm just
no sense I turned into the other blonde
guy me and Jay are both kill Carris
is or whatever his mate is
called and I'm Frosty the
Snowman St is
Frosty we're actually streaming live on
YouTube as well at the moment and I
can't remember why I did it but when I
set the stream up it made sense Twitter
on Twitter what did I
say we stream on YouTube most
most um but we're also streaming how
many viewers we've got on Twitter do you
know how many viewers we got no none
zero yeah I'm not shocked y tter I have
it open I have it open and it still says
zero well I didn't advertise the fact
you've never done it
before I many followers on Twitter or X
or whatever the hell it's called today
um so I'm not really surprised really um
wait can I retweet it oh I can I don't
know but talk to much for a minute for
no
reason I'll share it to my like three
extra followers I've
[Music]
got did Jay just is he coming back G
he's probably gone for a he probably is
he probably is that's absolutely
true so anyway the I I made a
special thing for Jay uh I know he loves
space whales right and so I found a
spacewell radio show called Leviathan 99
by Ray Bradberry that I put up week yes
Leviathan 99 it's more or less he took
Moby Dick Ray Brad bir took the story of
M dick and translated into something
sci-fi it's really good but space whes
for Jay that's his Christmas present
from good is it an old story
or he's back I did need a
we uh is that is that an audio story
it's yeah it's it's an audio drama right
Jay I was just telling him I I put up on
H Professor cringe I put up a special
story for you it's a space whale Story
by Ray Bradberry I know you'll love it
called Leviathan
99 space whales space space whale story
it's
R
huh from Wales going to space like like
Peril
Ahsoka no because that makes no sense
because that would be stupid soay
Bradberry would anybody put that in
anything Ray rare Berry would yeah from
the 70s
70s it's Ray bradberry's take on Moby
Dick called Leviathan 99 and it's my
Christmas present here it is that we
have three viewers on Twitter now
because I retweeted
it hey you said you're three people and
they came in they came in they came out
I said three all of them like oh my God
why am I not watching Sidetrack on
Twitter I I don't even know how it works
let should go four shall I start
watching
no um but yeah space
whales stupid I see one of them got
bored immediately um oh my God I got
kids
um a shoker I actually was one of the
most if I'm gonna pick a TV show that I
loved hated loved hated loved hated it's
a
Sher that's the one I expected the most
from and got the least out of I guess
yeah and um and Mandalorian season
actually Mandalorian season 3 was just
as bad it was like
well that was a good episode that was a
[__] episode well that was a good epode
a [__] episode I was like why isn't that
why isn't that dinosaur eating that kid
like yeah Mandalorian was very stop
starty with me yeah you go from mind of
Mandalore it feels like Lord of the
Rings for Star Wars and then the next
episode The Bird Fiasco that doesn't
make any sense timeline wise it
justel hedgehogs Sonic Sonic's already
got that down pat yeah Tom TR hedgehogs
Sonic we're getting a Sonic 3 so that's
gonna happen with Shadow honestly I'm so
in for that the Sonic the Hedgehog was
the first movie I ever saw in 40x which
is like where that seat moves around
with you and it was so much fun I'm
hooked on that stuff now sex secular
monkers yeah do specials are pretty good
especially giggle yeah Giggle was the
greatest episode of the
specials the the the BL World Blue
Yonder was all right I did enjoy it but
the Giggle was
amazing which one was the giggle have to
remind me the last one with I
didn't it was
good after the first one people a lot of
people switched off because of the
political like there was there was like
a a whole trans trans part of the story
line and people didn't like it fair
enough whatever if you don't like it you
don't like it whatever yeah but then the
following two episodes
were really good really good and I think
if they' have if they they'd have not
done the first episode it would have
been
better yeah gotta have the MEEP the Meep
we gotta have the Meep whatever we got
to do to get Meep and who is the boss M
maroy has the Meep like come on who
Miram maroy
yeah what did she play that [__] she
was in
profession Harry Potter she's a crazy
little
yep oh she's the best person in the
world every time she's on Graham Norton
Show I know my Facebook clips for the
next month are
great my favorite clip of her is she's
talking about she's walking through a
park and there was a man in a tree who
fell out of the tree and she tugged him
[Laughter]
off and I know her telling the story
would be even funnier which is the best
part about it yes it is it
is I don't know what it is about Graham
Orton show but it's by far like I I love
M Conan O'Brien I like John Stewart I
like anybody and everybody but Grandma
Norton does it better than anybody ever
could
is he is funny I love it when he does um
he doesn't do it anymore I don't think
but he used to do Eurovision but it was
just because even though he says he
loves Eurovision he was just sounded
like everything he says is sarcastic so
it was really
funny he still does it does actually but
yeah can Disney stop ruining things no
um they don't want to yeah his
commentary is like oh Poland's very
interesting yeah that was
nice sounds really really saky um but he
says he's not he doesn't try to be but
Terry wogen did it before that and he
was the same he just everything came
over and he was like ah this is that's
an interesting way of doing that but the
Eurovision is mental um but anyway any
did anybody have any other things they
loved or anything they really really
actually we done loved we've done
disappointed I'm a bit drunk now I don't
really we've done both we've done oh at
least I've done yeah I we've all done
both I didn't do
movies movies do your movies okay okay
okay well I'll go quick anatomy of a
fall past lives across the spiderverse I
think are the three that like just got
me and infinity pool I really like too
but that's a little bit out of normal
people's taste uh the ones that
disappointed it or were I just straight
up didn't like this year disappointed
was last Voyage of the demer or de deer
whatever the hell uh the the original
like the first couple chapters of um
Dracula where he's coming to these
states it just was it didn't live up to
what it should have been it was like BC
One they did kind of it was advertised
really cool where it was like
fantasy great it it looked really cool
and it just wasn't it wasn't good the
first episode was good or episode
episode uh oh they showed it over here
Jim oh maybe we're talking about two
different things we had a thing over
here with Dracula and then we had we had
like three
parts um and it was done a series and
the first oh no it was two parts the
first episode was great and then the
second part was terrible are we talking
about the same thing maybe I know I
knowy plus did Interview with the
Vampire but no no not that no
um the demer was like he wasn't like a
Dracula like person looking like he
looked like a monster like the big
winged kind of Beast kind of no not no
it was on a sh crossing the ocean oh
that was years ago anyway actually we
had a Dracula series over here was I
just expected a lot from it and it just
didn't give what I thought it would uh
the movie that pissed me off this year
though was Expendables 4 that I don't I
just it as as much it's supposed to be
dumb fun and they couldn't even get dumb
fun right like seemed
really didn't it really thank you Brazil
it just seemed really phoned in I it was
just
like well it was supposed to be a leak
Christmas spin-off that they turned into
the fourth movie and it's just like if
it's gonna be the Lee Christmas spin-off
make the movie primarily about him you
don't necessarily need Sylvester
Stallone you prove that sure but like
still you could you have the access to
make a good movie you have the right
team and everything but
ah
yeah car that that Dracula thing was
really the first was really good and the
second episode was shocking it was awful
it was like a BBC version of um the Bram
stokers Dracula that's what I thought
you were on about for a second um and it
but it was a couple of years ago now but
it was oh it was almost good
um I can't think of Mel just like really
made me like properly angry at the
movies the problem is we've had we've
had a bunch of movies this year that
have really disappointed me but almost
everything Marvel have done has been
disappointing everything DC has done has
been disappointing Blue Beetle was
awful um I you know it's just it's it's
all the stuff that's come out left field
like like like stormy said who knew I'd
enjoy
Barbie I mean I I saw the very first you
know uh clips from Barbie I mean not I
guess there were set Steals and it's
like what the [__] is this you know and
it was I it's it's further proof of why
I don't read um prepress anything you
know I I I kind of tend to ster away
from like announcements or what whatever
on movies or TV shows because I want to
be surprised in the theater now a couple
times that's bit me in the ass but you
know it's like I had no idea what Barbie
was about I just saw the steals of them
I think they were roller skating in on
Venice Beach in the bright and I go oh
my God
they're GNA do to this what they you
know they did to uh Land of the Lost and
it's just like oh God but pleasantly
surprised very well done very
intelligently written and directed and
[__] funny oh my God it was just
hilarious loved it loved it loved it
Blue Beetle is not better than Barbie oh
I I don't get me wrong I don't want to
watch Barbie in
either um but Blue Beetle was awful
Harris how can you well it it wasn't it
wasn't awful it was literally it it was
kind of like Rebel Moon before Rebel
moon in the sense that every single
thing that was in it had been like one
for one done in a movie before it it was
just if it was done in if if Blue Beetle
came out in 2015 or 2017 we all would
have liked it it wouldn't have been like
oh this is the best superhero movie of
the year but it would have been a just a
middle of the road enjoyable film
where I do really like Barbie Noah
bombach and Greta Gerwig which
congratulations they just got married
the two people that wrote Barbie who are
some of the filmmakers in the world at
the moment uh the more you think about
Barbie the more it doesn't make sense
within its own world and the the the
film falls apart the more you actually
intellectualize it and you don't have to
intellectualize film but the filmmakers
made that film too intellectualize about
so the more it falls apart and for those
two filmmakers who are two of some of
the best filmmakers in the world at the
moment it is both of their worst films
and I'm not saying that that's a their
all of their philography is great but it
is the worst film where blue I came away
from Barbie thinking I'm not sure I
should be a man anymore I think
men men [__] don't don't join Barbie
world because you don't get a house to
sleep at at night if that's the case
yeah I'm a misogynist Barbie's the
villain in her own movie and that's one
thing that people forget about they they
wrote
Barbie so you know for me there was a
comment who was it from uh Brazil yeah I
went to go see it out of my own volition
you know it's you know I knew it was
very controversial once it came out and
there's the whole you know Oppenheimer
versus Barbie kind of thing going on but
no I want to go see it just because even
though it was controversial I wanted to
see for myself and form my own opinion
and it was really really good and I do
that a lot with you know a lot of people
will just utterly hate movies you know
that'll be you know um I've got a
relative that just hates on everything
and uh I don't let that taint whether I
go over see it or not and you know I you
know it's like I really wanted to go see
Land of the Lost and it was sadly
totally butchered by everybody in the
production so much
fun that was awful it was aw CH chak
chak no it was awful will faral in films
shouldn't be allowed okay hey David B
what what about Indiana Jones was doll
of destiny were you surprised about
I you know I you know I went in I saw it
in theaters and you know it was not what
I expected but it was completely
different but it was it was like a
different more adult version of uh
Indiana Jones it was like well Stephen
Spielberg said once upon when he was
doing promotions for Schindler's List
he'd never do another um another Indiana
Jones where the Nazis were in it because
he always played off in those films he
played off the Nazis as these bumbling
idiots and once he came out affected by
Schindler's List he knew that was not
the case and so here we have new
filmmakers with a very heavy Nazi theme
but these were real Nazis there's like a
shootout you there's this train scene
and there's this shootout there's all
these uh uh things that comes up in uh
Indiana Jones that you don't know what
the Nazis are going to do in the be you
know in the other films oh the Nazis are
going to lose but here the Nazis were
actually [__] vicious [__]
absolutely vicious and then you see
Indiana Jones in the very beginning is
this kind of broken
disheartened you know uh yeah I thought
it got really bad reviews but I
absolutely let that was a different take
it wasn't you know did y'all were y'all
more when y'all went into seeing Indiana
Jones were we all more of the thought
process like this is getting bad reviews
this doesn't look good I'm not very like
confident in what Lucas film is putting
out right now this is going to be a bad
movie and then it surprised you and it
was better than it was going than you
thought it would be or did you go into
it like this is gonna be an Indiana
Jones movie they've got a good director
they've got the right people behind it
and then it was just like maybe not the
Indiana Jones movie you were thinking of
where were y'all at because I number one
guess I guess I kind of went in Curious
you know it wasn't directed by Spielberg
so this was the
first yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean you
know Crystal Skull was kind of
disjointed you know I felt you know to
be honest you know but it was Indiana
Jones was wanting to go see it and I was
aware of all the bad reviews and you
know and and the crashing absolute utter
Devastation of the box office numbers
were
horrible but it was it was like there
was a it was an adult version it wasn't
of of Indiana Jones it wasn't the
serialized Saturday morning kind of
cartoonish thing this was it actually
took you know his old age way into
account it took his um I mean he was at
the life you he had nothing left you
know and then you learn and and by the
way spoiler alert there's a spoiler
alert coming you know you find out that
his uh son was killed which pissed me
off I'm just like come on but I was
devastated you know and then everyone
else is going sh boof's dead
yay and
entertaining anyway
I I think it showed that this is a this
is a movie for an adult audience not in
a triple X head but it wasn't the
fun you know ramping themes and so so
forth you had really evil guys that were
I mean they were evil there was no
question you did not know the outcome of
the actors you know of the characters
were they going to live or die at the
hand of the Nazis and um and then there
was the devastation him telling the
story about his dead son and his dead
son going off to
war because essentially Indiana Jones
was an overprotected father and it was a
it was yeah the character was the same
but they were played completely
different completely different themes
and I think that's why at least for me
it was an awesome film one of the great
triumphs of this last year but it just
didn't get a recognition for that
because everybody else was looking for
the the childhood 1980 1980s version of
Indiana Jones well the Indiana Jones
film is you said it bombed at the cinema
but it did very well when they released
it on electronic sale people Cinema to
watch it but they did watch it at home
oh I bought it I mean I went to cinema
and I went and bought it you know
pre-ordered at home because I led the
movie I mean it was I thought it was
really good
yeah welcome back Matt hey Matt I had to
go toilet
again i' I've only been once everyone
noticed I've only
wants I had to go for an ice run
that's more than you though yeah that's
true um the thing I have with Crystal
Skull I would say the Crystal Skull is
overly hated but for me the crystal
skore is an okay movie with some really
bad bits in and it's got some it's got
but the problem is when you think back
on it all I remember is the ants the
size of
dogs the The Swinging From The Vines
with a really bad green
screen the nuclear keep up with Jeeps
going at 50 miles hour I'm sorry that
just like who knew that if you're gonna
survive a nuclear Bast all you got to do
is jump in a fridge no that really just
bug the [__] out of me the whole
refrigerator being launched across the
it just oh my
God
rolling he would have the door would
have opened and a liquidated Indie would
have slau yeah yeah was like that's not
how physics Works um and like say the
ants the size of dogs attacking him and
there and and and the end bit with the
with the UFO flying off but like Sarah
said Kate Blanchett is at least
fantastic
K Kate Blan is amazing I think Sarah
said that pretty was fun no it wasn't it
was stupid um but you get you get a bit
silliness and you can you can excuse a
bit of silliness but that was a bit too
much for
me my problem with dial of Destiny is
it's an okay with a it's an okay film
it's not a bad film at all and I quite
enjoy it with a terrible ending the
ending is awful it builds up to
this you know it really does build up
towards the finale and it's just stupid
and it's just it's it's a bit like the
only film I would compare it to um is
that sci-fi movie that I hate by um
thingy with the oh what's it called the
with the with the quantum mechanic stuff
at the end I'm always bitching about it
that I hate it so much Mania noell
Interstellar it's like inter the best
sci-fi movie of the past decade I love
stupidest movie of the last decade
you're right Harris the
absolute stupid the best of the past
decade s thank you I said the best of
this past decade and you immediately
said know I 100% agree with you mate
that it's a stupid film and should never
have been allowed to be made in the
first place 100% agree with you um that
the robots that are big boxes and
they're somehow walking what the was
that about um and u a tidal wave is
coming that's not how waves work when
the on a different planet it makes
perfect sense on literally any that like
that is that's within the laws of
physics that like that worked and it
makes perfect sense it only works if to
be be fair the whole ocean they've just
happened to land in a shallow bit and
just off the thing there's a massive
Cliff Edge under water and that that
because waves don't work like that waves
need they build up and energy builds up
and they go up our planet gravity
maybe oh also quantum mechanics then
that's not how quantum mechanics
work no one knows how quantum mechanics
work I was about to say tell us how then
like let us know then
you tell us
all quantum theory is theoretical every
single theory is all theoretic so what
is in theory and the main thing that we
have with quantum mechanics the problem
is that it doesn't the very very small
and the big or the the micro or the
macro there's no there seemingly no
connection between the two so yes okay
something on a Quantum realm can be true
but it doesn't mean that that that can
affect the macro it just doesn't so that
whole thing where he's looking through
the this bookcase is [__] so you're
saying there's a bit of quantum Mania
going on yeah it's just work sorry um I
am a quantum mechanics genius probably
not really is that even quantum
mechanics the whole that it's the thing
theas saying I mean wasn't that more of
a translation between 3D and 4D space no
it was to do with quantum mechanics and
um I'm looking the rocket scientist yeah
I shouldn't really argue with a rocket
scientist I'm just asking I'm just
asking twice my favorite part was when
all the okra died
but yeah I mean all the okra dying yeah
I'm not a big fan ofra my mother tried
kill me with okra once upon a time she
had like she grow it all the time and
make okra gumbo okra soup okra bread
okra Jam jelly I mean okra pancake I
mean she just had too much okra on her
just said you realized
scene wasn't a realistic opition it was
how who how who presented it to
him the
aliens Oh I thought he meant the
director no I understand that but he
wasn't dead at secular monk did make a
great comment after Spielberg was
originally going to direct Interstellar
but gave it to Nolan because he thought
Nolan had a better grasp on the material
that's a th% right and Jonathan Nolan
who's doing Fallout was like literally
like also tapped on like specifically as
alongside as brother Christopher Nolan
which was great but would would you
rather have seen the Spielberg version
or would you rather have seen the
Christopher Nolan version that is
whether you believe in the science or
not it at least tries to be more sciency
where Spielberg if you don't like the
the lack of science aspects of
interstellar where it does kind of Veer
into theoretical Spielberg would have
been only theoretical it would have been
f it would have been
more it's
boring I I recently within the last
couple of years watch 2001 yeah space
that ending that ending scene is very
trippy very like that obviously didn't
happen that's just what he saw isn't
that kind of like the same thing with
interstella that's just what he
experienced oh well Matt has a
tremendous point that I think tells
everybody to [__] off I mean that would
that's really yeah because end of 2001
he's seeing himself in the bed and he's
translating another yeah yeah Matt Matt
went this round somebody get [__] M
trophy I watch
first 2001 but I I I saw that and then
thought hang on that's obviously what
Interstellar took inspiration from like
yes I think you're exactly right that's
nailed on D but it's not his perception
because then he has a physical he's able
to physically interact with his
daughter's
room so he's able to Bush a book isn't
and he's able to affect um
something watched it now that then gives
Credence to um stormy's point about the
fourth dimension because the fourth
dimension you can time is not is not a
linear thing it's it's not I mean time
not linear for us we have the x- axis
but we also live on the third dimension
with the y axis time's not linear for us
necessarily either whether we perceive
it as such or not it's not and you add
another dimension and it's a hole it
blows that out of the water as well we
can blow the it was perception out of
the water though because he was able to
physically react with the world on the
other side of the
bookshelf I no because I think what what
he saw what he did and what he saw I
think are two different things so he was
able to perceive was different to what
he actually did because he must he
obviously interacted with his like
daughter's past past self that happened
but what he saw because he can only see
three dimensions was right yeah you know
I just want to say I just got to
interject we're giving Nolan so much
[__] here right about you know the the
the tial wave the the boxy robot you
know and and the fourth dimension thing
but we're just don't have that kind of
passion when it comes to the Meep
yeah I mean know was like you know I'm
good I'm kid oh I'm evil [__] them all
you know we just you know and it's just
you know and then there what was it the
the the reverse thermal driver whatever
the hell that's rocket had we're not
even touching that in terms of the
engineering but man let's just go nail
Nolan God don't get restarted on that
[__] engine drive and they [__]
they reversed it and all of a sudden the
cracks in the in the pavement just start
feeling themselves how the [__] does
that happen I mean here we're getting
down in einsteinian physics you Nolan
and then like whatever the [__] goes on
to Doctor Who well okay yeah I actually
think that was one of somebody said that
on one of the channels or one of the
things that doctor who isn't science
fiction and I Sly went oh crap no it
isn't it's always been science F always
your video was saying that huh Matt
wasn't that one of your videos that was
like your second or third one Davis
recently and said I'm he said I'm gonna
I'm gonna lean more into fantasy and I'm
like well it's always been fantasy like
it's not like the fact that the Tardis
exists
isn't you know I really want to do
something how did you affect other Sor
[__] I mean I really want to try to
come up with something that really is
camb Boolean flat mathematics I'm I've
been I mean I'm just I've been obsessed
with that I I actually have a book full
of notes on Cambo and Mathematics let's
write into a movie I I'll write the the
movie Parts you write the smart parts
well make sure that I get the the the
fors the fields medal at the end please
I just that's just hey I'm okay with
that we I'll be the chewbaca in the
background I don't need a medal as long
as my name's on I get cash um and anyway
anything that Chris Nolan does at least
it's not a Michael Bay movie
so okay okay okay real quick because
expion who is the more divisive director
Zack Snider or Michael Bay Michael Bay
really I think it's
Michael B is like he's divisive but he's
more like he's more more of the general
audience is willing to watch his stuff
than I think Z point
exactly I think Michael B makes me more
Angry interesting yeah I mean it's just
is like everything turns into a
Terminator movie you know Michael B
films have have really good
soundtracks all have Lincoln part i' got
to
go like Michael directs a good movie and
then he gives it to his mentally ill
brother he must owe money to edit it and
then he's ment do a film now um and then
he's sort of like m b look I got a
rhythm I got a rhythm to it and he's
going yeah Rhythm and it just does a
stupid like I'm gonna have the film
going bahahahahah and then we're just
gonna have a really random slow motion
scene right in the middle of it and then
we're gonna go again it's just it's
edited by like a [__] is said it not
even some this mentally ill because
that's not fair to the mentally ill
people it's a
[__] has edited it you just saved this
a little bit there yeah well actually
working mental health so I suddenly
realize halfway through my sentence are
like I don't that's not my ethics at all
but I'm a bit drunk so excuse me but
it's a [__] it's somebody that was just
like I I hate film so I'm going to ruin
this film on purpose that's what it's
like it's like it's edited by somebody
that hates
movies um so just like oh really hates
um Michael Bay maybe it's actually
Michael Ba's
worst from you g
[Music]
um so I think that's it I'm gonna forget
everything I said in the last two
minutes it's Michael Ba's worst enemy is
his editor and I don't know why he keeps
giving his films to this person because
he hates him and he keeps editing just
the films badly or he's giving it to Ai
and it was an earlier version of AI and
now actually Michael Bays are gonna
start getting quite good in the future
because AI is getting better maybe
that's it AI
[__] AI cannot create [__] didn't we
have an argument about this like a few
months ago yes we
did yeah didn't Matt win that my stance
has not changed AI cannot create
something it can only going past
experiences AI is
stupid So within the time that we had
that
conversation right now as of last week
in China it happened in China so I don't
know like what the if because you know
the information they release is like it
goes through a few different sets of
eyes and people before they actually
release anything um there was an AI that
won a writing contest an internation or
a national writing contest in China
so and and China's got some good writers
I mean three body problem that people
that did Game of Thrones are literally
doing right now as we speak I I have I
I'm not saying AI cannot write good
stuff because it can because it has a
lot of good source material it just
cannot create something original no but
that's the point isn't it that I would
argue that people don't create I think
we had this argument actually people
haven't been Crea don't really create
they they do variations what AI is
getting better and better at those is
Faking it to a f that's that's it with
with when when a journalist writes
something he writes or she writes with
their kind of view on the world when an
author writes a book they write with
their view on the world when an AI
writes something they they write with
everyone's view on the world and it's
not authentic and you can
tell
yeah I agree but also that's like what
movie feel like nowadays you know it
they're written to be so General versus
like any kind of like Niche anything
which which is nice whenever like an
indie kind of film or any kind of
independent type of film is one person's
perspective which is very nice because
that's what a movie's been for a long
time it helps you put yourself into
somebody else's uh shoes where nowadays
it's like the Marvel movies like yeah we
might have the main character but you're
probably going to like the other
characters just as much and we're not
going to actually focus on the main
character we're going to focus on the
general story of what's happening in
this world and kind of just drag you
along for a bit well I got this kind of
brings me back to a thought I had at the
end of Rebel Moon you know they had
there was the AI driven robots the
Warriors that kind of gave up became
pacifist once the King was dead no
matter what you did to them they would
just wouldn't fight back that was the
most part of that whole movie honestly I
know right and then the little girl put
the crown of daisies or flowers on the
robot's head and and he could have you
know ended that the the rape scene right
but he he he could have sided with the
Warriors and he kind of
didn't was like I'm G kill y'all at the
very end he kind of Rises up out of the
grainfield with he's got those antlers
on now and a bigger more onate crown and
and now I'm really curious what the hell
went on with
him
well now you get to wait for the Zach
night or 4H hour cut of the movie the
actual version of the movie that they
wanted to release and instead of doing
that they're going to release two
different versions of the same movie
just for the sake of doing it when is
that one coming out do we know that's a
great question is it gonna come out
before the second part I don't know I
second part so
it's it was you know because I saw the
the AI you know robot you know he's like
down on his leg he's just you know he
was doing his robot thing and then he
came out with this big really worn and
the horns like what it's that's that was
for me that was the highlight of the
whole movie I mean you know what must
you know what the transformation of this
AI bot you know War rob you know battle
robot what did he go
through when he saw somebody stand up to
defend the people that killed his King
story-wise that doesn't make much sense
to me where he's one of the most
interesting people and should have been
probably included if you're going to get
someone if you're recruiting people to
do something you recruit the fre robot
that just helped you do what you needed
to do but then not not even like
story-wise you hired Anthony freaking
Hopkins to voice this dude whether he's
on set actually doing it or not you're
paying Anthony Hopkins to voice this
guy and you give him maybe five maybe
seven minutes that's where the 150
million of the 166 million quid
went it very uh very apocalypse now
anyway
we're gonna call it night because I
promised my wife I'd be off at 11
minutes ago so well so much for that
ship yeah um but my kids are gone so
that's the main
thing right here gone um I well they're
my step kids they gone to their dads so
their stepdad has got younger kids so
we've said they can go there so that
they can they just evaporated because
you weren't giving them
[Music]
attention oh yeah
it was suggested and I went that's a
brilliant idea let's do that um so yeah
so uh no more so I've been very tired
all said let's go I've stopped drinking
I text a wife near 45 minutes ago to
bring me more alcohol and she hasn't
done she text me about going what you
want and then has just completely
ignored me since did you respond to that
what kind depends what's open though so
I mention Jager and Coke
nothing I think she might have G out
anyway I need to start drinking and
getting quickly wrong and not off but um
guys thank you have more beer when I go
downstairs yeah oh yes oh yes thank you
so so much for spending your Christmas
Eve with us um Everybody in the comments
and that's been watching us tonight
thank you so so much because I really
did think having a Christmas Eve show we
might get no one watching at all but
actually turns out there's a lot more
people out there that um hate their F
want to their families for out so um did
the robot have P near two hours
just watched well David we don't know we
don't know we'll have to wait for the
Extended Cut and then it did sat there
getting very very angry um Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas Laura and just
just guys just have have a brilliant day
have a lovely day tomorrow um spend it
with your family or on your own I might
go and spend it on my own um I'm trying
to wonder don't forget Doctor Who is on
tomorrow to enjoy it
oh I don't want to watch
it why well there's two of them now who
is me there's two of them there's two
who now what's the point there's not
there is David Tenant still not doing
fine do you not know how time works I do
know how time works but also the doctor
can't appear gw's doctor came from the
future from from the interstellar talk
earlier I'm not sure he does just make
it easy watch my video watch my video it
explains it all I'm not watching there
is not there is not two doctors it is
there is a David Tenant timeline and
there was a shooting gwall timeline and
they converged at some point because of
the time time the toy makers meddling
that's it that's it and then they
separated again all and then they
separated same way when pet Davidson met
David tenan it was two different doctors
the same way when matx Smith and David
Tenant met it was two different doctors
it's exactly the same thing well well
it's also you know I I you know I let me
just
bring let's just bring up the previous
century when they had there was an
episode where they had three
doctors running around yes there was but
timelines and I got five or three was it
three or five that they're the yeah
every
classic multiple doctors when you had
different timelines though so when did
or how did they end up inside each other
because that that the new doctor was
right inside
David the toy maker basically [__]
with reality and made something
impossible that shouldn't happen happen
and it had to be something to do with
the gun also the energy from the
gun splitting the realities because it
was right after he got shot in his two
hearts but they but they in the episode
said they by regenerated that made it
sound like he
he separated yeah but they also said
they also said to shoy gatwa said to
David Tenant you need to slow down you
need to stop because you're going
through this is this is rehab for time
Lords we're just doing it in out of
order I'm better because you got better
he was from his future he said it in the
episode is timey WHYY but why was he
inside David Tenant then he's always
been inside because the toy maker [__]
with the universe like [__] that
shouldn't have happened happened like
the unit guards literally shot bullets
and Rosies came out like the universe
was [__] I mean I
mean God I prefer jimm you need to drink
more man have a h have another beer now
made more sense than Doctor Who Um I
might have Doctor Who is not gonna make
not gonna make sense moving forward
they're gonna lean more into
fantasy because it's Disney Mickey Mouse
is going come on plut let's really
[__] Mickey Mouse for another two months
[Music]
so does the Christmas special come out
on Christmas Eve or Christmas yes
Christmas day it's Christmas special
over here BBC Doctor Who used to be that
that was the thing on Christmas Day for
years for like 10 years it was like
that's the thing everyone was like oh
let's get the queen out the way so we
can watch Doctor Who Um and it was
never y say never watched the queen
no if there was something I could give
less of [__] about long kill the queen I
I'll go straight American at that screw
the queen screw the monarchies we don't
need Queen more than we did what you
about the Americans might I'm from y'
you see yolay right here you think that
what what's this say that ain't America
that's
Texas I'm British I and through and
through Cups of Tea the goblin song from
from from tomorrow
[Music]
if the if any Monarch ever landed in any
port in Texas I would be waiting with a
shotgun
okay story about that contic Yankee and
King Arthur's Court damn right I'm I'm
ready classic American literature by the
way the thing is though when you're
there ready you got British soldiers
actually know how to do their job
protecting her but no she's dead now so
we won't be protecting I can outo any
British any day of the week I was raised
to do better I was raised any anybody in
anybody in the United States whether
you're North or South can outdo a
British soldier that's that ain't
nothing maybe the Navy might have a
little bit of difficulty that's I can
tell you out of experience that is not
true through experience I'll tell you a
story when we get
off oh God here it comes it's going to
be thank you so so much Merry Christmas
everybody we are before we leave can I
pull a stormmy I have this whole list of
things I've written down that I've
watched this week and there's been a lot
of them I just got to got to say
something go
[Music]
go oh [__] that minute one minute one
minute I made
it one check okay no check mark no good
Wonka two check marks myestro two check
marks poor things two check marks ien
one check mark migration one check mark
ironclaw